now speaking of joe rogan
let me ask um the following question
he's uh currently doing a podcast with
gordon ryan
and uh probably going to try to convince
him and you as he's already been doing
to move to austin what are the chances
of the donahue death squad coming in
to austin and opening a school in austin
and making austin home
so i can attend the classes there i
would definitely have to think about
that
i do know that i
personally love new york yes but
every single person in the squad
despised new york
and wanted to leave for a long time so
um uh what was the nature of your love
for new york by the way
uh it was truly an international city
like i'm a big believer in the idea of
of breadth of experience and
if you want breadth of experience
usually requires extensive travel
but training people means you have to be
in a fixed location
working according to a schedule and
that pushed those two push in different
directions new york was the compromise
where
everyone from around the world came
there so you had breadth of experience
of world culture
but at the same time you had a fixed
location so you could run a training
program that produced world champions
so it was the ideal compromise um
it was a fascinating thing to teach
classes of over 120 people where
literally the entire
world was represented on the map and go
outside and
see the same thing it was truly
uh the world's leading international
city it was
um it was like the world's unofficial
capital
fascinating place to live so um i loved
it but the squad hated it for them it
was like an expensive
um things they never actually lived in
manhattan they always lived in
new jersey or long island had to commute
in so all they ever saw was the bridges
and the tunnels
the expensive daily parking fees that
they only saw the worst of new york
and um despite my pleas for them to move
into manhattan they never did
and so they they hated it they because
when all you see in new york is the
bridges and the tunnels and
yeah the the parking garage that's not a
pleasant thing
so um i i understand where they're
coming from so
uh then when covert broke out
they wanted to to move to puerto rico
and
uh and and work there now
puerto rico is a beautiful alternative
to new york it's
in many ways has many advantages over
new york it's physically beautiful the
the uh the people are wonderful and um
uh it's it's a it's a just a wonderful
place to spend time
um freedom low taxes
all those kinds of things that puerto
rico stands for yeah
it's uh texas on the other hand i know
everyone is compromised right
texas is a compromise between those two
actually i must say that everyone
on the squad myself included loves texas
i
that there's no question about that i
know um gordon loves it
uh gary uh craig nikki that
everyone who comes here just loves texas
this that
is incontestable um
of course in texas there's uh many great
cities austin has
uh uh always been one of my favorites
i've i
love dallas i love austin um
and uh it has the advantages of better
infrastructure as a place to train
it has a much higher population density
so that you could
get a larger number of prospective
students and form a larger squad
um it would uh it would definitely be a
fantastic place to to open up a gym um
i couldn't give an answer off the top of
my head it would be a big move if we did
make that move uh but the
the basic idea would be very agreeable
to everyone on the team i will say that
well i'll just have to call my russian
connections to threaten the right kind
of people and
uh i definitely would love
the way you approach training the way
you approach the martial arts is
uh is something that's uh that i deeply
admire
as a scholar of these arts so it would
be amazing if you do come here
but either way it'd be amazing to train
together
you